do you think that feminism is a hate
group
so I was actually standing here thinking
about that and in a certain sense I
agree but not the first thought I had
was yeah this is hatred towards man but
actually I think it's not that I think
it's
I I sense in modern feminism a certain
amount of hatred towards
femininity
you know like I think about what is it
that a lot of feminism over the last 30
years is about and it seems very much
about having the kind of power
Prestige and sort of the the picture of
success that men have and created rather
than
the kind of feminine version and picture
of success
why do you think that is
um
well I I guess it's it's a movement that
at its foundation seems to
really
derive in in the political sphere and so
obviously if you're
a party in the political sphere you know
you're going to be going after political
power not
um oh
the public life that's not important
it's the private life that's important
let's
I mean that that wouldn't be a very
successful political uh position
certainly wouldn't get you a lot of
power and votes so if it if that was a
movement of some part of feminism and
and you know I'm sure there is a part of
feminism like that I know in the nordics
like there's there's a lot more actually
women choosing to stay at home and you
know with with kind of you know quite a
lot of free choice but I would guess
that that part of the movement would
probably not be the most ambitious and
driving and grabbing boats and pushing
other people kind of to the side and
winning because it's not a very sharp
elbow kind of position it's it's more
about like yeah no like you know your
relationships at home with your family
with your extended family with your
community that's what matters don't
worry about what's going on in Berlin in
London and in Washington that's kind of
not what matters in life why do you
think it's okay for women to say men are
trash but it's not okay for men to say
women are [ __ ]
well I think you see that in
uh many of the dichotomies you know from
like probably going back to like
communist stuff where there was like oh
the people who
build the businesses they're rubbish but
the people who work in the businesses
they're great and you know now there's a
whole black white divide so I mean it
just happens everywhere where you have
very militant groups and why is it okay
um
yeah I I don't know how that came about
I think it's a real shame I think it's
Preposterous and I think when we look
back on it in a certain time hopefully
people will go
how is that not sexist racist classist
Etc right yeah
um
you think that men should be
to have
a since women have the right to choose
in the UK it's abortions legal up to six
months do you think that men should have
a say to have a financial abortion where
they don't have to pay child support
because women have the choice not to be
a mother can he have the choice not to
be a father
in the name of equality
no I don't think so
okay I think I think they're I think you
you
um I mean that's one to really
contemplate I'm sure there's some
scenarios where it but no overall I
think um
you know whether whatever kind of
accident or decision-making power you
had you know it's you've done it and now
you're
you have an obligation to that right so
you agree with women having the right to
choose I do
you think that that favors women though
and not men
because if if I wanted to then I could
go get pregnant by a rich guy and then I
have I have a check for 18 years
I think it takes some part of him doing
something as well no I I agree
um but you have you have like cases
where like there's an entire Reddit
threads where women are just trying to
figure out how to get pregnant by men
and it's almost like the laws allow
women to be predatory
yeah well
I don't think we should infantilize men
or anybody you know we're we're adults
and we take decisions we get into bed
with somebody and that's I I agree I
just don't think a woman should be
entitled to a man's money
I think we I can work like why why do
you why are you why are you entitled to
his money for
Infinity 50 custody like why which that
should be like the from the off the bat
and no money
well I'm not it is still gendered but
it's not entirely gendered I know cases
where the woman's the you know very
wealthy chef and she's paying money to
uh you know some
I mean I I would agree I agree both ways
like I don't I don't think child support
should be a thing I was just curious
what your opinion was though
I think there should be an obligation
and yeah you know as a as a man who's
part of this or a woman you know you're
you're in on something that is going to
last for you know 18 20 years and you
need to spend money you think people
should be more careful with who they
sleep with
I am no person to comment on that but
um
where
okay where is the justice for the people
that said what do you think of the
phrase believe all women
well I think it I think we have gone
very much to the extreme uh recently
where somebody's life can be completely
undone through mere accusation
and I think that power does need to be
curbed in some way hopefully we'll find
a balance in the next whatever
I hope so too thank you so much for
sitting down you're really fun to talk
to did you did you see my Instagram post
or did you just walking oh okay okay so
what's your name uh key okay
um and what do you think about feminism
I think it's different now okay I think
there I think that a lot of uh maybe
first and second wave feminists might
not agree with the new wave right now in
terms of how things are being uh done
and what they're fighting for and not
being able to necessarily support in the
same way like by what they actually say
you know I mean I feel like a lot of a
lot of things are said right now that
are not actual beliefs but more so the
talking points that sort of disrupt the
idea of communication and conversation
so it gets a bit hard to actually have a
genuine conversation so yeah
um what you know what's interesting I'm
going to show you this stuff
um did you know in 1848 and in the late
1800s and 1900s
feminists were bombing churches and
planning assassination okay didn't know
that so it's all like to me it's always
been a it's always been a hate group why
is
it Define you find a hate group that's a
good question I I I I think they
feminists want privileges at the cost of
men I think yeah I I think I can I can
hear that yeah yeah yeah
um I also think that most people that
fight for anything would do it at the
cost of uh anything as long as it
supports what they believe yeah so well
I that's interesting
because to me it's just like they scream
equality so I just I just want to see
yeah yeah that that is the one thing but
I think that equality
I think the argument for equality is one
that isn't uh it's nuanced surely right
and I think that it depends on what you
mean by equality and right what what
needs to actually be equal versus what
needs to be uh what's the word based on
Merit for example right you know and if
it actually makes sense for certain
people to be in certain positions
yeah women need feminism in 2022. I
think
I don't know because I don't think I
don't think feminism I don't think
feminism is the same thing I think it's
different I think it depends on what you
Define feminism as and I think that's
one of the issues of George holders no
because the phone okay might be a bit
uncomfortable I don't know
yeah uh cool yeah okay
um
I think yeah I think feminism means
different things to different people
nowadays and depending on who you're
talking to
you get a different answer so I don't
know if we need the
uh very particular
uh
view that feminism has right now that is
essentially
equality equality equality until
equality means men having something
yeah it's this weird sort of like yeah
we want your quality but not not if men
get something instead of women and I
think that's a bit it's a bit weird to
say that you can't you can't scream
equality and not actually be about
equality
I think man sense of women have the
option not to be mothers like they can
get into like so so if you get a girl
pregnant right she has the option to get
an abortion yeah do you think that men
should get the option to have a
financial abortion yeah yeah I do I do I
truly do that but I I wouldn't frame it
in that way but I think that that if you
actually have a choice in the matter I
think that's quite important and I think
that men don't really get the
opportunity to have a choice in the
matter and um yeah that needs to change
thank you so much for sitting down I
appreciate it
I thought this man was very
his outfit